let's see my little girl  that's my  perfect little girl  man that smile that smile didn't change  those eyes didn't change  those eyes  they would get her out of so much  trouble  didn't matter how old she got she would  always be my baby girl no matter what  she  you know how much trouble she was in it  didn't matter she was still my baby girl  you know and  yeah i would just melt  these are all i have left now  people would meet her and just  fall in love with her  she just had this presence  [Music]  i don't know what it was it was just  magical  there's so many good memories over the  years but the one thing that i hold dear  to me  is the hug that we had  before she left for the trip in the  driveway  [Music]  you